a lot of times I would go and substitute
teach and I I loved it so much that I
actually had to instate a rule where I
wouldn't go to the same school more than
three days in a row because I would just
fall in love with the kids and I would
lose sight of my dreams you know I would
be like I don't need to act I can just
devote my life to these kids and I'd
want to adopt them and take them home
and um so I would only be at a school
for three days and then I would have to
switch schools and I actually after I
did Save the Last Dance I still I didn't
make enough money on that movie to
survive so I went back to teaching and I
got in trouble because when I would
substitute teach in high schools the
kids would cut class to see chenelle
from Save the Last Dance So the
principal called me and was like you can
only do elementary schools you cannot do
high schools anymore cuz these kids all
want to meet Chenille it's not okay oh
my God how weird when you're like life
intersects like that so weird they were
also like how's she teaching high school
isn't she in high school I was like nope